[Musique]
soit
si Naham inaugurait le funk
des likes, un apprentissage incroyable
n'oubliez pas le microfootball allergique
les enfants partent le lendemain pour aller à l'école
et le jour comme les lumières, la vie noire
des victoires dans différents de l'école
et finir la journée après le travail, bon Wickham
bien à Tingo
[Musique]
Je préfère être sur la plage parce qu'ici
Je me sens plus détendu
Je me sens plus à l'aise, c'était très bien
parce que je suis avec mon ami, je suis dans le
plage, nous pouvons, par exemple, nous asseoir au
côté plage de Miramar faire un
chose s'il n'y en a pas il n'y en a pas dans une autre création
comment enlever le masque et respirer
[Musique]
les pêcheurs du village ont enseigné
les étudiants comment pêcher comment vivre
quelle est l'économie qui est tant
souffrance et comment ils ont eux-mêmes été
capable de nous nourrir sur scène
pandémie, il est très important qu'ils
faites savoir aux enfants que le poisson n'est pas là
au supermarché, il est tellement respecté qu'il l'est
dans la mer il faut les sortir
[Musique]
ou non